ces signatures du déclarant et le cas
échéant de son épouse alors ça je
comprends pas parce que normalement on
le colle chambre pourquoi
[Musique]
mais ça c'est pas à nous de changer ça
changeait tout
[Musique]
changer pour
changer tous
change
[Musique]
si je suis votre homme d'affaires et ça
fait mans parce que je voulais que tu
ailles oh mon mari et moi une situation
plus intéressant parce que je veux faire
toujours plus et devenir vraiment chef
d'entreprise m'améliorer tout ça c'est
la faute à certains bender
et puis en plus il ya des choses qui
m'ont bien fait yeux c'est que j'attends
matin et puis j'ai mes enfants
ça va pas durer
c'est tout t'es pas la mort
mais va venir tout à leur maman arrivée
monde du show on est parti voir un
client est arrivé tout de suite c'est
très important de vivre avec les enfants
de les avoir en permanence c'est une
riche expérience de vivre un vrai avec
eux lorsqu'un enfant quand il a trois
ans quatre ans vous regardez vous dit
papa je t'aime fort très fort ce sont
des choses qu'on n'oublie pas il vous
reste est malheureusement les un petit
travail
rentrer chez eux et n'ont pas le temps
est beau ou même certaines fins non pas
ça
mais ça il faut toujours être une fois
de très doux la douceur n'est pas
typiquement non plus féminine et vous
avez des hommes qui sont très doux dans
le geste
[Musique]
puisque son boulot moi je me ferais
temps il faut avoir une sacrée patience
ya s'appuie aussi la présence est simple
parce que bien que le père est à la
maison on est très maternelle enfin une
mère est très maternelle ce sens une
obligation de présence auprès des
enfants et mon bureau terminé bon bah
c'est mes enfants quand il n'est pas
question que je fasse un sport que je
pense avant tout à loisir au personnel
ou alors je le conçoit qu'avec mes
enfants alors que londres et il peut
dire bon bah ma semaine et terre mais je
peux aller à la pêche une après midi il
le fera sans scrupules alors que moi
j'aurais toujours ce scrupule
change
il ne fait pas minaj pour les moins
bons moments il fait la cuisine il fait
la vaisselle il s'occupe des enfants il
fait tout ce que je voulais qu'il fasse
maintenant on va plaire à tous ces maux
n'a plus de femmes de ménage il y aura
d'autres tâches à faire à ce moment là
où je serai contente tout serait pas
contente on verra
[Musique]
on rendrait il aime bien voir entraîner
midi une soirée puis que je dois
m'absenter nez un peu triste je le fais
quand même parce que c'est
travail ce serait une femme ce serait
pareil à une femme qui attend ce moment
lundi soir quand on est chez des clients
spa brouillé plus je peux pas accepter
qu'ils soient tristes à cause de ça déjà
parce que je trouve ça fait partie de
mon travail qui n'acceptent il doit au
contraire être content que je travaille
mes salles contrario que soit la maison
il est peu que choisir
ma femme arrive
vers midi midi rigueur
et puis
allez là jusqu'à au moins
deux à deux ans et demi qu'elle tue vous
comment vous et c'est là la différence
que je fais c'est quoi avant oui
c'était vraiment éphémère
la ja un plaisir l'attend c'est vrai
avec ma petite tournée tous les deux là
on attend on attend maman active à
toulouse et puis là aussi c'est très dur
j'en aurais tu vois je préfère du sud
alors au début pas de problème je
travaillais andré m'aider c'était très
bien
mais nous avons donc je suis arrivé à
afghanes y est le double de sandrine en
gagner donc à ce moment là nous avons
décidé qu'il arrête de travailler
puisque son salaire me semblait un
appoint
thomas manger la veille à l'école
je ne sers pas ma femme je lui rends
service aussi je ne suis pas prenons un
mot tu es gros son larbin je suis son
mari je lui dis bien
ouais
je ne fais pas pleinement le ménage je
n'ai pas de position exigé
mais il ya des mamans je souhaiterais
que savait dimanche matin par exemple je
me suis levé à ces deux bonnes heures
pour aller travailler je reviens et dès
11h et puis la table du petit déjeuner
du matin est un pas en reste et je
n'aime pas ça ne me plaît pas j'estime
que ma femme pourrait le faire
évidemment lorsque l'on dit homme
d'intérieur
c'est un volet on emploie des c'est ce
sont des mots qui sont inscrits au
vocabulaire enfin disons je suis à la
maison
il est évident je ne fais pas beaucoup
de ménages parce que je ne peux pas être
partout si je prenne mes nerfs vous fait
pull de
1,6 à lui faire je le ferai je sers
pense et j'espère maintenant
[Musique]
je travaille toujours dans le jardin il
ya mille choses à faire
[Musique]
j'estime que dans 70 maisons je n'ai
peut-être jamais rapporté un centime
mais j'ai travaillé beaucoup
dire j'ai planté beaucoup d'armes je la
trouve assez joli au point de vue des
opérations et si je n'ai pas à porter
d'argent si un jour mes enfants veulent
revendre ou je ne sais quoi
j'espère que ça représente un certain
capital ce que j'ai fait je les fais
surtout pour ça aussi pour ça
je me sens sûr de moi
parce que je suis
c'est peut-être prétentieux mais
imprégné j'ai l'impression de s'être
imprégné de la nature voyez je me sens
très fort pour ça
s'il avait fallu que je vive la vie
d'homme au foyer un appartement en ville
je l'aurais fait si vraiment la
nécessité s'est imposé mais s'arrêter
assez dur
si j'avais à élever des enfants on vit
en hlm pour dix ans
j'aurais quand même eu un dada sinon
vous avez pas d'objectif dans la vie en
somme un essai le malheur de beaucoup de
femmes c'est tout pas voir ça
pourquoi une pensée qui peut faire des
choses aussi qu'il peut créer le fait de
faire de la sculpture d'avoir aménagé la
maison comme elle est s'il avait fallu
que je paye un entrepreneur pour faire
tout ce qu'il a fait mais j'aurais pas
pu et je crois que là vraiment aiguë ça
a été très bon pour lui et pour moi
parce que celle-là valoriser tu vas tout
ça c'est fait
étant donné qu andré ne travaille pas je
travail de fond
mais je me rends pas compte que je
travaille deux fois plus parce qu'en
plus comme j'ai un travail qui
m'intéresse je tiens est ce qu il que
tout soit fait comme je mon idéal
pour un certain idéal de soi même on
veut se surpasser toujours où je pense
parce que je veux
comment réussir c'est parce que j'ai
voulu gagner plus d'argent parce que ma
marraine
m'avait emmené quand j'avais l'âge de 10
ans chez elle et qu'elle était très
riche et j'avais pu comparer quant aux
moyens de mes parents ce qu'elle pouvait
faire alors certainement que mon ombre
me disait toujours qu'il peut réussir en
partant de zéro c'est possible en france
c'est possible c'est libéral qu'en
france nous avions une politique
libérale et que je pourrais réussir
quand même tu n'as qu'à faire des
assurances à ton compte et ces deux là
vraiment que l'idée a germé ensuite j'ai
lu des livres de reader's digest
souhaité indiquer comment réussir dans
la vie avec une machine à écrire un
classeur et dans ma cuisine j'ai acheté
une classe heures et une machine à
écrire nous avons travaillé tous les
deux j'ai ramené l'argent je ramenais de
miel d'argent qui comme elle j'ai dix
ans que je gagnais par rapport aux
autres geôliers je venais normalement si
vous voulez oui quand même heureusement
qu' être parce que j'en ai jamais pu
monter mon affaire je comptais sur toi
quand même je comptais sur ton salaire
parce que débute à venir les nîmois donc
c'est quand même grâce à toi si le plus
construire mon portefeuille ah bah oui
parce que il ya eu un temps mort où il
est évident que quand ma femme va
commencer à
se mettre à son compte a essayé de le
faire de l'assurance il ya eu le temps
meurt c'est à dire qu'il fallait une
heure et notre paye pour compenser ma
femme n'a pas gagné d'argent du jour au
lendemain comme ça il a fallu pendant un
bon moment j'ai pas lier dix ans
c'était la vie à deux mais c'est pareil
c'est à dire que vu que je te faisais
l'écart
on se voyait à peu près une demi heure
trois quarts d'heure par jour et c'était
un
très gros calvaire de vivre dans ces
conditions quand on a décidé tard est de
travailler je me sentais très heureuse
au départ lorsqu'on allait se voir
davantage tallec mouassa qui vit moins
énervé mais c'est d'un prêt qui n'a beau
c'est après qu'il a fallu
qu'on s'est aperçu des différences visa
de la société quoi au départ on s'est
pas rendu compte on s'est lancé dans
cette entreprise sans savoir et
conséquences et c'est après que l'on a
rêve que l'on a eu des problèmes parce
que on a eu plus ou moins lié les deux
amis qui n'étaient pas d'accord ça nous
a fait repenser
voilà il ya eu un petit fléchissement de
nous allah et l'autre camp c'est un
petit peu buté
mais moi j'avais la méditer famille des
problèmes des éducateurs tout ça qui me
disaient non non nous tromper en france
il ya une personne qu'il fait donc ce
serait bien en suède mais ici non c'est
pas possible parce que l'enfant va se
sentir à part des autres
la grande et elle va elle vacille un peu
bas vous avez une période nouvelle va
dire non mais moi j'en resterai à la
maison un jeu je lèverai mes enfants
j'aurais beaucoup d'enfants et puis il
se passe un laps de temps et puis le
dire mais je travaillerai je veux être
indépendant
je crois que j'étais livré qu'il ferait
j'attendrai mon travail enfin je sais
pas bien tous les livres qu'on lisse et
c'est au contraire de notre vie c'était
le père travaille là mais reste à la
maison de la tendresse le dont le père
au contraire apporter l'iman viril enfin
un bris pas des ses enfants c'est tout à
fait opposés or moi qui voulais une mère
parfaite et bien je ne trouvais pas ça
dans notre couple et ça me faisait
vraiment de problème parce que je
voulais absolument un bon équilibre pour
mes enfants j'ai pas pensé à ce moment
là de moi même comme je pense maintenant
que c'était faux qu'on pouvait très bien
faire autre chose ce n'est pas
nécessaire de suivre cette ce modèle que
nous ont imposé la société et c'est là
que j'ai réagi et puis que j'ai pensé
différemment et que maintenant on y voit
mais à 20 ans que je voulais que ce soit
comme tout le monde et bien j'avais un
gros problème parce que ça ne pouvait
pas d'abord en vrai d'époque comme tout
le monde ils avaient décidé autrement
que les autres et j'étais contre lui
parce que j'ai trouvé que ce qu'il était
c'était pas bien
alors sp1 consciemment et santé c'est
culpabilité que moi je lui tenais 40
elle était c'est moi qui lui donnais
je faisais je le rendaient responsable
de ne pas avoir assumé ce rôle de dom
j'ai ma mère elle ne travaillait pas
elle ne rapporte pas d'argent mais
c'était formidable que nous avons dû en
discuter avec nous à nous raconter des
histoires le soir elle avait toujours du
temps
je les adore ma mère je la trouve
formidable je trouve le plus fort ni
d'aprr aucun homme qui milliardaire
voilà c'est ça et andré pour moi c'est
pareil il n'a pas besoin de rapporter de
l'argent pour que je laisse comme
j'aimais ma mère ma fille a des qualités
mais longeant la des grandes qualités il
a de la tendresse de l'univers
je n'ai pas pris un côté féminin j'ai
pris une fonction
mais le travail que je fais autre jeu
rang n'est pas typiquement féminin
ça ne me dérange pas que l'on considère
que je sois
féminisé ça ne me dérange pas du tout
parce que je suis sûr de moi
me souviens pas avoir été senti
inférieur à ma femme du fait qu'elle
rapporte l'argent
si encore un grand mot qui est lâché
cette histoire l'argent
elle est supérieure à moins au point de
vue savez de gestion
elle a l'habitude de manipuler l'argent
je trouve ça tout à fait normal
j'ai jamais souffert de demander de
l'argent à ma femme parce que je n'ai
pas beaucoup de besoins
je me contente de peu
mais il arrive quelquefois que je devais
on a besoin de changer un outil alors
j'ai mon piège du coup je lui ai dit
voilà
je
ne la perceuse et qu'en sais tu veux je
te fasse des trous tu payes du fait que
j'ai eu les le travail donc j'ai pris
les responsabilités
mais on n'a pas inversé les rôles en
réalité je me sens toujours une mère et
mon mari se sont toujours un père
certainement et pour moi c'est toujours
l'homme
ma femme me fait toujours rire elle dit
des choses elle parlera peu dans tous
les sens et c'est amusant mais elle me
donne 100 francs
je lui demande ses enfants pour faire
les courses
on a pendant la semaine il faut 200
francs pour faire les krostons la
semaine et puis je me débrouille avec
saint andré formidable dans son genre
je ne veux pas
qu'il y ait de désaccord entre nous
je veux que ça marche toujours
il ce ne serait pas encore une valeur
matérielle que je voudrais me fâcher
avec ma femme
ça n'est pas ma famille qui fait
l'autorité
elle est autoritaire
j'ai toujours essayé de mettre ma femme
en avant
je les jette toujours j'étais content je
suis toujours content quand ma femme a
réussi une affaire où je suis content
pour elle
au début j'ai sembler lourde puisque je
n'étais pas préparé pour ça mais
maintenant je pris mon rôle au sérieux
puis dans le fond pourquoi par ce soit
moi plutôt qu'à des fins m à valoriser
en fin de compte ça valorise les femmes
en général
même si c'est lourd
je les accepte parce que ça me permet ça
m'apprend à lutter
tu me donne de la joie c'est que je sais
qu elle allait content du moment et elle
est contente de ce qu'elle a fait de ça
ça me suffit je suis bon bah ça mais
je suis un nouveau de mireille mais je
le suis encore beaucoup plus maintenant
qu'il y à seulement 10 ans 15 ans même
vague je crois que c'était la bonne la
grande réunion d'avoir arrêté de
travailler
quand ma femme était jeune beaucoup plus
jeune je veux dire je rate en avait
19 ans 20 ans elle me disais mais
pourquoi tu m'aimes
parce que je suis jolie est ce que tu me
trouves jolie là je lui dis ça n'a pas
de sens aujourd'hui pour demain tu n'es
plus joli à la jeune tu aimerais plus je
t'aime toi ce que tu es mais je ne sais
pas pourquoi
j'ai pas besoin de nous marier
réussissent dans la vie pour les mais
c'est pas mon problème
moi j'ai besoin qu'il soit bien
moralement qui se voit bien qu'ils nous
rendent heureux qu'ils soient
comme il est quoi
comment peut-on appeler ce que je fais
personnellement je savais pourquoi dire
ma profession il m'arrive de dire au
sixième fois en plaisantant je suis à la
retraite
enfin moi je trouve pas qu'on a une vue
différente de nous par an parce que en
bref il paraît que son père enfin un
parc qu'ils travaillent pas lui dire
mais sans quoi ils allaient même et
jardinent comme son père il s'occupe des
animaux comme son père j'ai rentré dans
une usine je suis resté 35 ans je
m'occupe de mon jardin de mes volailles
elle a peint la chasse
je suis très très pris
je ne perçois pas je suis à la retraite
je
pense pas
pouvoir dire que
vannes entretient son mari s'il n'y
travaille
dans la maison ou dans la propriété où
il s'occupe de ses enfants
j'appelle se faire entretenir plainte
l'homme ne sait rien du tout alors là la
pana tard mais autrement
si vous voulez l'homme qui travaille la
femme qui est dans la maison qui est
assis princ
alors là c'est il n'y a rien de changé
du tout
changer tout
changer
pour eric
tous
dans la charge
[Musique]
s'il y avait un troisième enfant dans le
coup il pourrait pour faire face mais il
le ferait je pense qu'ils feraient face
c'est ce que vient de pêcher mais
certainement qui souffrirait mais dès
qu'il l'aurait qu'il verrait rires et
puis qu'il aurait le dp il assuré je
pense que vous n'êtes pas de problème
ils voient que les inconvénients les
contraintes mais quand il serait là il
aurait les avantages collectifs tous ont
allaité enfants ce serait pas un drame
mais je ne désire plus d'enfants parce
que je n'ai pas la sainte et nerveuse
est-ce que je suis trop attentif ce
serait très dur
[Musique]